there are new warnings tonight from the
administration about the threat from
china the country's top
intelligence official says that threat
is a defining
issue of our time national security
correspondent jennifer griffin looks at
the evidence tonight from the pentagon
america's outgoing intelligence chief
john ratcliffe in a new op-ed
warns that china is the greatest
national security threat faced by the
united states since world war
ii quote the intelligence is clear
beijing intends to dominate the u.s
and the rest of the planet economically
militarily and technologically
ratcliffe spoke to foxnews.com china is
the only country capable of challenging
american supremacy across the board
supply chain issues foreign investment
cyber issues 5g
china is the only country that threatens
american supremacy
the chairman of the joint chiefs echoed
that view as well
the longer term almost existential
challenge
is going to be china it just did uh
we have to come to grips with that i'm
not saying you're gonna have a war with
china
uh i'm saying we want to prevent a war
with china even nato is shifting its
focus beyond russia
china does not share our values it
undermines human rights it
bullies other countries the chinese
communist party continues its crackdown
on hong kong's pro-democracy activists
jailing 24-year old joshua wong agnes
chao and 26-year-old ivan lamb who have
endured solitary confinement
and were sentenced to prison this week
for organizing peaceful protests
china's defense budget is now the second
largest in the world
it's navy the largest the chinese ma'am
have
25 shipyards to r-1 the u.s navy
is however more lethal with more
precision weapons the u.s has 11
aircraft carriers compared to china's
two
which are soviet relics the state
department announced it is reducing
visitor visas for chinese communist
party members
and their family members from 10 years
to one month due to their quote
nefarious activities more than one
thousand visiting chinese researchers
fled the u.s since this summer according
to the justice department
which says they burrowed into u.s
research labs on university campuses
and stole cutting edge technology while
hiding their connections to the chinese
military
mike